In 1815,
Mount Tambora erupted in Indonesia,
killing an estimated 92,000 people.
It was the biggest eruption
in recorded history.
And yet, Tambora was
about one-seventh the size
of the smallest supervolcano.
There are about a dozen of
these monsters worldwide,
and the last one went off
26,500 years ago in New Zealand,
blanketing most of its island
in a layer of thick ash.
Now, it's extremely unlikely
that one of these supervolcanoes
would go off anytime soon,
let alone multiple eruptions at once.
But, for curiosity's sake,
what would happen
if all the world's supervolcanoes
erupted at once?
If every supervolcano went off,
you'd have a hard time finding
a safe place to flee to,
because almost every continent
is home to at least one supervolcano.
For example, there's
Yellowstone in the US,
Ngorongoro in Tanzania,
and Toba in Indonesia.
So, basically, no matter where you are,
you're out of luck.
But at least you'll have a warning,
because weeks or months beforehand,
the ground will tremble with earthquakes.
Then, when E-Day arrives,
the earth-shattering sound
would be a dead giveaway
that something wasn't right.
When Krakatoa,
which wasn't even close
to the size of a supervolcano,
erupted in 1883,
it released a roar so loud
the sound traveled nearly 4,800 kilometers
across the Indian Ocean,
shattering windows and
deafening people in its path.
And since even the smallest supereruption
would dwarf Krakatoa's eruption,
there is really no telling how
much damage this would cause,
but it would be epically catastrophic.
And let's say you were
lucky enough to survive
this first wave of destruction.
After that, it would be time
to find a fallout shelter,
because these supereruptions spew
billions of tons of ash,
volcanic glass, and rock
thousands of meters into the air.
Not something you want to
inhale or be in the path of,
since this cloud of ash
doesn't just travel up;
it also expands out,
crashing across the landscape
at jet-fighter speeds.
It would collapse buildings,
contaminate water supplies,
and bring down any
power grids in its path.
And the fallout would extend
for hundreds of kilometers,
so any cities nearby a
supervolcano are immediately toast.
As are any planes that attempt
to fly people away from the danger.
And keep in mind that ash travels.
When Toba erupted 74,000 years ago,
winds blew ash all the way to India.
So if all the supervolcanoes
go off at once,
volcanic debris would
spread across the globe.
When the eruption ends,
the disaster will have only just started.
Because for the next six months,
much of that supervolcanic ash
would linger in the
stratosphere and block sunlight,
causing global temperatures to plunge
by as much as 15 degrees Celsius.
That's close to the difference
between summer in Rio
versus Anchorage, Alaska.
In fact, just "little"
Mount Tambora's eruption
alone set off the "Year Without a Summer,"
where frost and blizzards plagued much
of the Northern Hemisphere.
So, multiply that by the
12 or so supervolcanoes
all spewing thick black dust,
and you've got a worldwide volcanic winter
for the next few years.
Tropical forests,
which can't handle cold weather,
would wither and die,
bringing down the
millions of animal species
that live there.
And it's about to get even bleaker.
You know that saying
"out of the frying pan and into the fire"?
Well, in addition to ash,
those volcanoes also belch toxic gasses,
like sulfur dioxide, into the atmosphere.
And after a few years,
just after the winter finally ends,
those gasses would start to
fall from the sky as acid rain.
When the Laki volcano
erupted in 1783 in Iceland,
it rained down so much sulfuric acid
that it devastated farmland
and wiped out half of all livestock.
The next year,
a full quarter of
Iceland's population died
in the resulting famine.
So imagine that,
but everywhere.
And since Laki wasn't even a supervolcano,
we're looking at acid
rain for the next decade.
Say goodbye to civilization,
because it probably can't survive
a decade-long global famine.
Now, there are a few places on Earth
that, while still suffering from cold
and acid rain and famine,
would at least be free
from the actual explosions themselves.
Like volcanic islands
such as the Galapagos,
or even Hawaii,
which ironically is
famous for its volcanoes.
But the thing is,
these volcanoes slowly
release flows of lava
rather than violently exploding.
So, you could at least enjoy a nice view
as civilization implodes.